let's start out with good
good spoof had a very profound and uh
not necessarily very positive influence
on philosophy
and uh basically lukas and others in
philosophy opened up a tradition that
where the underlying current is that
what goodl has shown is that mathematics
is impotent
to describe reality
and therefore
reality can only be described by people
who don't really know mathematics that
is philosophers
so philosophers like that intuition
right but it implies that there is
something beyond mathematics
that allows you to make sense of things
that assign truth
and
slightly deeper when you say that you
like computation and you value it and so
on and you see its limits it implies
that you see what comes beyond these
limits and you're using that thing
beyond the limits to think
and i don't think that you are
everything in my own mind that i can
observe when i observe myself perceiving
when i perceive myself
reflecting when i perceive myself
reasoning
is computational it means that i go to
from state to state
in a somewhat deterministic way the
random parts are just deleting bits that
i computed before so i have to do it
again the randomness and determinism
doesn't help me so the part of my mind
that is relevant to my thinking
is fundamentally computational what
girdle discovered and is often
misunderstood and also by griddle
himself
is is a very important thing
what girdle has discovered is not that
truth is deeper than proof
that was in some sense the suspicion
which he started with he knew that
in his view that truth is platonic
that things can be true or not
regardless of whether we find out or
whether it can be found out
and he hoped
to find a notion of truth of proof that
could reach truth
and he found that it couldn't and he
found this in a devastating way
and he drew the conclusion that there is
truth that cannot be found with
mathematics
and the opposite is true
there is no deeper notion of truth than
proof
you see
perception cannot be true or false
perception just is
physics physical events out there in the
universe cannot be true or false they
just are a pattern that you observe is
not true or false it just is
right you could be erroneously thinking
that you're perceiving a pattern when
you don't because you're suffering from
false memory or a delusion or whatever
that makes your thinking a perception
inconsistent but the pattern itself is
not true or false it's an interpretation
that can be true or false and the
interpretation is has to be in a
symbolic language to have the property
that can be true or false a perceptual
interpretation by itself is not true or
false it just is
right so in order to be true or false
you need to have a language
and the language needs to be defined in
such a way that truth can be established
and the process of establishing truth is
a computation
and there are two types of languages in
which truths can be defined
and the language of classical
mathematics is a stateless language
it's one where time doesn't exist
where everything happens all at once or
in some kind of eternal moment
so if you want to go from state to state
in this language of eternal mathematics
in the stateless language you just
assign an index and then you iterate of
the index and you do this in a single
instant in one moment
and the stateless mathematics has a very
beautiful property it allows you to deal
with infinities because you can now
construct functions that take infinitely
many arguments in a single step
perform an operation over them in a
single step and give the result back in
a single step
it's a language in which you can assign
a value to pi
right in the computational system you
cannot really assign a value to pi you
can have a function that gives you digit
by digit but you never get to the latest
last digit it also means that digit can
pi can never be written down in such a
way that you can have a process that
relies on knowing all the digits of pi
and consumes them to tune the outcome of
some physical process
right if you
make the switch to a stateful language
in which you can only go from step to
step
you're losing certain things you're
losing the ability to treat pi as a
value pi is now certainly a function
that you can only approximate to a
certain degree
and many other things stop being values
you get a fundamental difference between
a value of the function a value is
something that you have already computed
that you know how to compute by
extension
and this means that also that truth
changes truth is no longer this platonic
thing that precedes mathematics and
where we can use mathematics as a tool
to figure it out
it has to be contingent on the language
in which you use it if your language has
internal contradictions
then truth becomes impossible to
determine
right
you get into areas in this language
where it falls apart you can no longer
use it to express coherent thoughts
about reality and korean models about
reality
you can never make statements in the
language that you can prove outside of
the language so you cannot use your
language to prove things that are not
cannot be described in the language your
only hope to prove statements about the
universe that you exist in inner
language is that you are able to
recreate the observations that you make
inside of the language which means you
recreate a model of the universe that is
so good that it gives you what you
observe correctly and then you can hope
that the statements that you make in
your language capture something about
the reality outside of you that gives
rise to your observations but of course
you cannot know because it could also be
different
but if your language is not able to
produce what's on your screen
then your language is wrong
and hilbert basically gave out this task
to mathematicians to find a machine
any kind of structural sound language
that is able to run the semantics of
mathematics without breaking and what
goethe discovered is that the semantics
of stateless mathematics cannot be
recovered if you assume that there is a
solution to get stateless mathematics to
work
you will run into contradictions
of the way that google discovered
but there is a way out
you just
drop the notion of truth that is
independent of the sequence of
operations the number of the set of
steps that you took the algorithm that
you took
to get to your result
it means that when you have a
self-referential statement like this
sentence is false
right this is a sentence that of the
type that good has shown leads and for
contradictions if you assume that there
is a stable notion of truth
that is stateless
if you accept that truth is not
necessarily a stable value
and you look at the sentence then as
long as you look at it
the truth value will fluctuate
because the assumption that the sentence
is true will lead to uh the sentence
being false and vice versa so suddenly
you have no longer a stable truth
predicate and it just means that the
property of the languages in which you
can actually deal with truth and assign
it is that under some circumstances the
truth predicate will not be stable
and it's fine there's nothing wrong with
that
and uh this same thing applies to the
children's problem that um
turing was dealing with when he came to
the halting problem we defined
originally the turing machine in such a
way that we could translate stateless
mathematics
into algorithms
and this might require that you have to
go through an infinite sequence of steps
and if you make this assumption that you
sometimes in order to get to tools you
have to go to an infinite sequence of
steps you run into
contradictions so you might use an
unbounded sequence of steps that gives
you continuously results that's fine
but you cannot accept that anything
exists in any kind of universe that has
caused a structure
that is going to produce your solution
to the heartache problem that is which
would give you back stateless
mathematics
so basically what good and turing have
shown is
that stateless mathematics doesn't work
and when we look back at the history of
mathematics mathematicians have never
used stateless mathematics they only
pretended to whenever they actually
wanted to compute something with
mathematics they under the hood use
stateful descriptions they never took in
infinitely many arguments and performed
infinitely many
operations on them
and the intuition that stateless
mathematics makes sense is because we
had this intuition that continuity that
space and time in a continuous fashion
exist
why do we have this information well
that's pretty easy to answer right the
number of things that we interact with
if we zoom in we find that they are
discrete although observations have a
discrete resolution
in time and in space
all our knowledge that we store about
these
observables is has a discrete
number of bits that we can assign to
them
there is only finite number of
information that we can access and that
we can deal with as an observer that is
embedded in this universe so everything
was discrete to begin with but it's too
many parts to count
if you deal with too many parts to count
the inside that number of atoms that you
are in an ocean is a finite bounded
number it doesn't help you at all
because it's still almost infinite from
the perspective of an observer so when
you want to describe what the ocean is
doing it doesn't help to count the
molecules in it and to assign locations
to them and uh what are the interactions
it doesn't work there is too much
so when you look at the dynamics of too
many parts to count you're looking for
operations that converge in the limit
which means they behave quite similar
whether you're using a trillion or 10
trillion or gazillion particles
right once you have these operators that
give you the same dynamics under all
circumstances when you take more and
more elements to them
this this this part of mathematics that
describes the convergent operators
that's geometry and some of geometry is
uncomputable so you can only approximate
it
but our brain has discovered geometry to
deal with the world of too many parts to
count
and this plays into what you are
pointing out when you say that
our perception doesn't give us reality
it gives us something that we can work
with
of course the reality that we are
embedded in has too many parts to count
we need a different reality we need one
that we can actually handle even if it's
not computable it can only be
approximated and this experiential
reality is a very coarse simplification
it's about as coarse as a gaming engine
is when you play a computer game as
compared to real physics
it's not much better than that in many
ways it's even worse which you can
verify if you put yourself into a lucid
dream and look at the fidelity of what
your brain is able to generate light
switches will usually not work you will
not be able to read the same stuff twice
on the same page when you imagine it and
so on there's only so many bits in your
working memory the fidelity of what your
perceptual system can track and imagine
is limited
it's relatively easy to overcome that
don't really know what the number of
bits in my working memory is and that
would be very curious to find out
but it's not as big as i thought when i
was a child it's not infinite it's not
unlimited perception of infinity is
super easy to generate when your mind is
very finite super easy to overwhelm
my finite resolution mind
so uh this deep thing that good is uh
misunderstood that google has not
discovered that mathematics cannot reach
truth but that truth is no more than the
result of a sequence of steps that is
compressing a statement the axioms
losslessly and doesn't go beyond that
that was the deep insight and it's one
that basically has not percolated in
most areas of philosophy and even
physics yet because the physicists have
checked out the code base for
mathematics before that result was
obtained and understood so basically
that we need to switch from continuous
stateless mathematics to constructive
mathematics that was not understood back
then
and it needs to be understood now
so
basically my
question to uh somebody like donald
would not be so much how do you explain
the spectral gap from because i think
problems of this case of this type
are with the result of using continuous
notions of space-time
and infinities
and assuming them as given so it's a
statement about certain theories that
are
expressed in the language that has
inconsistencies in this language with
these inconsistencies you get to the
point that you cannot get certain
results there's also an issue of
computational irreducibility which is
difficult to understand in stateless
mathematics computational irreducibility
is a property of a system
that means that you cannot obtain the
state of the system
without running the system to that point
there is no way to predict the system
except by taking the system with all its
detail and fidelity and going through
the sequence of steps so you cannot
predict what the universe is going to do
when the universe is computationally
irritable you're going to predict some
things but not all of things and these
some things only with a certain degree
of certainty because you can
often not insulate them from the parts
that you cannot predict because they're
computationally irreducible
in a universe that is played out and
implemented in a stateless language that
is a confusing property
because the cost of computation doesn't
play a role when you are in a stateless
universe in a stateful universe the
number of state transitions that your
model needs to make plays a suddenly a
certain role and uh this
specter of computational irreducibly uh
dooms is large it means that you cannot
compute things for practical reasons
because you don't have enough
information yet you cannot have
information to make that prediction but
there is no deep miracle uh that is not
caused by the language when you discover
that the spectral gap problem is uh
incomputable so my question to donald
would be if you think that there is a
limit to computation that you can see
and previously beyond you would still do
something and make statements what is it
that you use to make statements beyond
the limits of computation
what parts of
of your mind are you drawing from when
you make statements beyond what a
computational system can derive